Salut les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux.
Vendredi prochain démarre en France
la 10ᵉ Coupe du monde de rugby.
J'ai hâte d'y être.
L'occasion pour nous
de revenir sur les mystères de ce sport
très populaire dans le monde entier.
Le rugby n'est pas un jeu de balle
comme les autres.
On fait des passes en arrière,
on utilise un ballon ovale et on pratique
les mêlées.
Rien à voir avec le football.
Et pourtant, vous allez voir que ces
deux sports ont une histoire commune.
Allez, on se retrouve tout de suite
sur mon terrain favori dans l'atelier.
La partie va commencer.
D'où vient le rugby ?
Le 1ᵉʳ novembre 1823, au cours d'un match
de football qui se déroule à Rugby,
en Angleterre, un certain William Webb
Ellis se saisit du ballon à la main,
puis court à toutes jambes
pour l'écraser dans l'en but adverse.
Le but est refusé.
Normal, c'était un essai, le tout premier
de l'histoire pour les amateurs de rugby.
Cette séquence légendaire constitue
l'acte fondateur de ce sport.
C'est une belle histoire,
vous ne trouvez pas ?
Et pourtant,
ça ne s'est pas du tout passé comme ça.
La naissance du rugby ne
doit rien à ce pauvre William Webb
Ellis qui n'a rien demandé.
Mais j'y reviendrai un peu plus tard.
Ce qui est sûr, en revanche,
c'est que le rugby est bien né de l'autre
côté de la Manche,
au début du XIXᵉ siècle.
Pour développer leur capacité physique,
les étudiants se retrouvent
à l'extérieur, dans une prairie
et courent derrière une balle.
Au départ, on joue uniquement au pied.
Toutefois, les règles de cette activité
varient d'une université
à l'autre
et deux courants se dégagent rapidement.
Dans un cas,
on se cantonne à jouer au pied.
Dans l'autre,
les joueurs peuvent prendre la balle
à la main pour la passer à un partenaire.
Le premier courant
dans le football moderne.
Le second, le rugby,
qui voit officiellement le jour en 1820.
Porté par un collège
situé dans une petite ville du centre
de l'Angleterre.
Rugby.
Les premières règles de ce sport
seront établies dans le même établissement
le 7 septembre 1846.
Et là bas, aucun document ne mentionne
l'exploit de William Webb Ellis.
Alors pourquoi lui attribue ton
la paternité du rugby ?
Tout part
d'un article de presse rédigé en 1876.
Un journaliste qui prétend
être un ancien camarade de classe d'Eli
relate l'événement.
Vous savez, la petite histoire
que je viens de vous raconter.
Le joueur qui prend le ballon
dans ses mains et le porte dans l'en but.
Le journaliste n'y a pas assisté,
mais il affirme le tenir d'une
source sûre, mais anonyme.
Dès sa parution,
le papier entraîne une levée de boucliers
des anciens du collège de rugby.
Ils affirment haut et fort qu'ils n'ont
jamais entendu parler de cette histoire.
Elle est bidon.
Qu'importe, de nombreux amateurs de rugby
s'y accrochent et la relaie.
Si bien qu'en 1895, c'est bien
le nom de William
Webb Ellis qui est retenu
par une commission constituée
d'anciens élèves désireux de mettre un nom
et un prénom sur l'inventeur du rugby.
Mieux encore, on lui érige
une statue à l'extérieur de l'école
et en 1987, on donne son nom
à la toute nouvelle Coupe du monde.
C'est la Coupe Webb Ellis.
Du coup, l'ancienne élève de la Rugby
School est entrée dans la légende.
Bien malgré lui, il meurt en 1872,
quatre ans
avant la publication de l'article
qui va le rendre célèbre
au rugby.
Pourquoi
fait on toujours les passe en arrière ?
Pour comprendre l'origine de cette règle
unique dans les sports de balle,
il faut revenir au déroulement d'un
match de rugby au milieu du XIXᵉ siècle.
C'est un énorme regroupement de joueurs
qui progresse
vers le camp
adverse en tapant aux pieds dans la balle
et en essayant d'aller la capter
quand elle touche le sol.
On avance que de cette façon,
les passes à la main
ne sont pas interdites,
mais les joueurs les évitent
car elles sont extrêmement dangereuses.
Et pour cause, la loi numéro 27
de la Rugby School de 1846 stipule
que le joueur porteur de balle
peut être frappé au tibia.
Résultat les fractures à la jambe
sont nombreuses et parfois très graves.
Henri Vassall,
un jeune étudiant à l'université
d'Oxford, en a fait les frais.
Au cours d'un match, il est victime
d'une double fracture tibia péroné.
Incapable de revenir sur le terrain
pendant des mois,
il passe son temps à jouer aux échecs.
Et c'est là
qu'on observe les pièces sur l'échiquier.
Il a l'idée, le fou, la tour,
le cavalier ou la reine avancent,
mais ils peuvent aussi reculer pour mieux
esquiver l'adversaire.
Et si on appliquait ce principe au rugby ?
En pratique, en transmettant
le ballon en arrière à la main,
on contraint l'adversaire
à s'avancer dans le camp opposé.
Un peu comme si on voulait encercler
le roi et réussir un échec et mat.
Par ailleurs, en passant la balle
vers l'arrière, le porteur est protégé
par ses coéquipiers,
ce qui lui évite d'être gravement blessé.
Grâce à Henri Vassal et aux échecs,
le jeu va prendre peu
à peu sa forme moderne
en devenant plus fluide et moins violent.
La moindre passe
sous la moindre maladresse qui propulse
le ballon vers l'avant
est donc désormais sanctionnée.
Ils sont bizarres.
A quoi sert la mêlée en cas de en avant ?
La sanction, c'est la mêlée,
Cette phase de jeu qui est codifiée
depuis 1872, donne encore une fois
au rugby son caractère unique.
Les Anglais l'appellent scrum.
La mêlée implique
huit joueurs de chaque équipe,
les avants qui sont liés entre eux
sur trois lignes.
Il s'arc boute
et entre en contact avec l'adversaire.
Les deux blocs s'encastrent alors l'un
dans l'autre pour former un cercle fermé.
Cela crée un tunnel dans lequel
un joueur ou le demi de mêlée introduit
le ballon afin que la première ligne
puisse lutter pour la possession du ballon
en talonnant avec l'un de leurs pieds.
La mêlée est une véritable épreuve
de force qui vise
à prouver à l'adversaire qu'on le domine
tant psychologiquement que physiquement.
Mais les rugbymen n'en sortent
pas toujours.
Didier
Game est un chercheur en biomécanique
passionné de rugby, a calculé qu'un joueur
qui entre en mêlée affronte
une poussée comprise entre 300
et 700 kilogrammes pendant 2000 secondes.
C'est le poids d'un piano à queue.
Résultat on recense en moyenne
seize zéro zéro blessures chaque année,
dont près de 800
traumatismes du rachis cervical.
La mêlée est aussi à l'origine
des oreilles en chou fleur
à force de se frotter
les oreilles contre l'adversaire.
Des hématomes apparaissent.
En terme médical,
on appelle cela une période de conduite.
Les vaisseaux sanguins explosent,
le sang s'accumule
et les cartilages s'enflamment.
Alors, pour éviter ce désagrément,
de nombreux joueurs
se protègent avec des bandeaux
ou avec des casques.
Pourquoi le rugby se joue
t il à 15 875 marque
un tournant dans l'histoire du rugby.
Cette année là, le match qui oppose
les universités d'Oxford et de Cambridge
aligne pour la première fois
deux équipes composées de quinze joueurs.
C'est une petite révolution
dans le monde du rugby.
Jusqu'ici, les équipes étaient constituées
de 20 joueurs.
Par le passé,
on a même vu des clubs aligner 25,
30, voire 50 joueurs sur le terrain.
Le match Oxford
Cambridge fait donc figure de test
et il enchante tout le monde, les joueurs
mais aussi les spectateurs
qui réalisent que moins il y a de monde
sur le terrain, plus il y a d'espace
pour le porteur du ballon.
L'essai est très vite transformé.
De nombreux clubs
imitent les deux universités et la règle
est officiellement validée
en 1877 à l'occasion d'Angleterre Irlande.
Le tout premier match international
à se jouer à quinze contre quinze, J'en
vois certains venir.
Et le rugby à treize, c'est pas de rugby ?
Eh bien oui et non.
C'est un sport dérivé du rugby à quinze,
mais qui n'a pas les mêmes règles
et qui a sa propre fédération.
Vendredi 8 septembre,
au Stade de France, c'est le coup d'envoi
de la 10ᵉ Coupe du monde de rugby.
Le quinze de France affronte les All
Blacks, autrement dit la Nouvelle-Zélande.
Depuis 1893, les rugbymen néo zélandais
se présentent à leurs adversaires
entièrement vêtus de noir.
Une couleur qui inspire
la crainte dans le camp d'en face.
Ainsi vêtus, ils porteraient le deuil
de leurs adversaires.
Comme souvent dans le rugby,
ce n'est qu'une légende
inventée par les journalistes.
En fait, le noir est un hommage
à la culture maorie,
le peuple originel de Nouvelle-Zélande.
Chez eux, cette couleur est symbole
de prudence, de sagesse, de constance,
mais aussi de vie.
Mais il n'y a pas que la couleur noire
qui effraie chez les All Blacks.
Le haka, c'est la botte secrète
des All Blacks.
Une danse ponctuée de cris et de grimaces
qui précède chaque match.
Le haka est une sorte de transe.
Les All Blacks scandent
les paroles, cognent le sol, se frappent
les bras et les cuisses et fixent
leurs adversaires de leurs yeux exorbités.
Littéralement, le mot haka
signifie à la fois danse et fair.
En maori, il désigne les danses chantées
par l'ensemble des peuples polynésiens
lors des cérémonies des fêtes de bienvenue
ou lors des combats.
Dans le but
d'impressionner les adversaires,
le plus courant est souvent interprété
par les All Blacks, dit en substance
Ka matters, karatéka Ora car je suis mort,
je suis mort,
je suis vivant, je suis vivant.
Les paroles auraient été inventées
par un chef maori en fuite.
Pressentant sa mort prochaine, il
se serait écrié Ka matters, je suis mort !
Mais en voyant ses ennemis s'éloigner,
il aurait finalement repris
espoir en chantant Ka ora, je suis vivant.
Ce rituel a été traîné
pour la première fois
par les rugbymen néo zélandais en 1905.
Mais si les All Blacks inspirent autant
la crainte, c'est
parce que ce sont des rugbymen hors pair,
au dessus de la mêlée, si j'ose dire.
Leur palmarès est impressionnant.
La Nouvelle-Zélande est le seul pays
qui atteint
quatre fois
la finale de la Coupe du monde.
Elle a remporté trois titres,
dont deux consécutifs
en 1987, puis en 2011 et en 2015.
Voilà, j'espère que cette
vidéo vous a plu et que le ballon ovale
n'a plus aucun secret pour vous.
Je pense que dès vendredi,
vous serez très nombreux dans les tribunes
ou devant vos écrans
pour soutenir le quinze de France.
N'hésitez pas à liker la vidéo
et à nous donner vos pronostics
en commentaires à dimanche prochain.
Et allez la France !